Good, it's lovely to be here anyway.
I've been really looking forward to this because I'd like to share with you some techniques that I have.
Techniques that I've been using and that I've found really quite life transforming for me.
Mostly taken from Reiki.
But also Qigong has been a big influence.
So I did Qigong and Tai Chi for about 15 years before doing any Reiki.
And also Pranayama is a feature as well of the kind of work we're going to be doing today.
I'm kind of waiting to see more names.
Everybody...
good i can hear you sarah has said she can hear me so i'm assuming that sounds that's lovely that's i love to hear things like that that's very encouraging i've never thought i had a fantastic voice but uh um in in in the terrible um sort of rush there i've lost lost the notes but i i i do know what i'm going to say fortunately um reiki
means universal or spiritual energy and the particular frequency of energy that we draw on is the energy of compassion and healing and it's it's an energy that
It's very subtle.
It requires practice.
We all do it, actually.
All parents do Reiki.
Every time you comfort a child, you're doing Reiki.
And it's like wellness.
It's unspectacular.
It isn't spectacular.
It seems that only the bad things are spectacular.
So, you know, it's very quiet.
is very gentle thing reiki somebody asked me last year how do i know how do i know when when i have when i can feel this this key this this this energy how do i know it that it's that it's working you know when trying to help somebody or themselves and the answer i gave
i think that they found rather disappointed i found it disappointing actually because i said well as soon as you you feel a sense of caring for yourself or for that person anyway i've called this um this session the space between this is my own working title because of the situation we're in this you see so it's the space between and the polarities defining that space
and the space that defines the polarities.
All right.
So we'll be doing a lot of that sort of thing.
But before we start, as I said, the, the energy is one to do with, with healing.
I'm going to try and shift my good, good, good.
I've just had to shift my window to access something.
Now,
Buddhism we there is a tradition of healing and the Buddha himself used healing he healed people and and he used this he recited this to heal so there was a very a very strong perception of
of words being part of one's physiology it wasn't it wasn't it wasn't like a kind of charm really it was it was based upon the knowledge that words and all sensory things of which words are made of really sensory fragments that are constructed into metaphors of meaning but they're not aside from the physiology they're part of it and that so
know they're coming from a a place of knowledge and the bhajang is such a the seven um factors of enlight enlightenment i'm going to read these actually because i know i probably forget them but the the first of course is mindfulness and the second one i'm having i'm having a go this uh the second one is investigation into truth and the third one is energy
And then you have, after the energy, you have rapture and tranquility.
And then the last two are concentration and equanimity.
There you go.
I've done it without having to refer to my list.
I'm very chuffed with myself.
Now, in Reiki, there's a thing called Reju, which is a blessing.
and it's i can talk about that more tomorrow when i talk about the history of uh reiki i don't want to talk about the history of reiki much today i want to get on with doing things um but it's basically a blessing but in a way the first blessing that that was ever used uh certainly within the buddhist tradition was the buddhism which is the bhajanga sutta and bunty has recorded this for us so he's going to bless us all
The long, the short, and the tall.
And if I can get, I've got an MP3 here.
And what I want you to do is just to breathe and listen.
You don't need to put your hands in gasha or anything unless you feel you want to.
But I'd like you to assimilate the words, just the sounds.
There's stories in the sutta that tell of healing.
and these seven factors also are mentioned but if we can just just drink in the sounds okay here we are you're on bunty
samsari samsaratanam sabadukkha-vinasane satadamme ca bhojange marasena pamadane bhujit vache cimei sata tibavamuttakuttama ajati majjarapyading amatam nibayangata
Hewamadigunupetam anekagunasangaham.
Hosadancha imamantambogangzachapanamahe.
Bojangosatisankatodamanangvichayotata.
Viryampitipasadibojangajatatapare.
Samadupe kabojangga satete sabadasina Munina samadhakata bhavati bahulikata
samvatthantiyabhinaya nibhanayacha bodhiyah etena satchavajena sottite hotu sabbada ekasmin samayena to moggalanchakasapam gilane dukkite disva bhojangi satta desayi
Te chatan abhinantitva rogam uchim sutankane etena sacchavacena sotiteho tu sabbada
ekadadamma raja pi gelane na bilipi to chunda tere na tam yeva vanapet vana saddharam samodit vana abhada thangha utasitha na zo etena satya vache na sotite hotu sabbada
sorry sorry sorry
Thank you, Bhante.
With Reiki, we have three sort of strands to the exercises.
And one is the breath.
The other is the imagination.
And the third is movement.
Now, the movement, you can do virtual movement.
It doesn't happen in too many exercises, but you do have movement in some.
You can visualize the movement if it isn't possible for you to move.
What I'm saying is that really you can do these exercises anywhere, even on a train.
And I do this.
Fully integrate these exercises into my life.
Even I'm a musician, so I practice the piano a lot.
And when I'm not practicing the piano, I'm doing these sort of things, the pranayama, reiki, a few asanas.
When I'm playing the piano, I do these sorts of things.
In other words, I use an actual technique which applies these skills.
They're not separate.
And that's the exciting thing about them, because you're investigating all the time with these sort of spiritual practices.
And it's like being a child and wondering what you're going to discover next, because you do discover things.
There may be very, very small insights, but a child only needs small insights to be delighted.
now the first strand then is the breathing now so we're going to go straight into the breathing and i suspect that most of you probably know how to do yogi breathing and it may vary from the technique i use um but um what i use is at the three-stage breath so expanding the stomach
and then expanding outward horizontally the chest.
If you imagine it, if you think it rather than try to do anything, it will work better.
And then a very slight, very, very slight lift at the end with the breath, not in a muscular way, you see.
And this brings me to what I want to offer
Whether it's any use to you, I don't know, but give it a try.
And what I want to offer is the idea of breath sculpting the posture.
You know, when we think, oh, I'll pull myself up.
And of course, the movements are all muscular.
They're all muscular.
But if you think what a pneumatic kind of power can have on the body, it's considerably greater.
And we pull ourselves up and we're breathing.
We're probably breathing in the wrong way.
So breath needs to be coordinated with action, you see.
So the breath is sculpting the posture.
Now, there are things that happen anyway.
With the in-breath, there are two things that happened that have been discovered in research.
And anatomists, some would argue about this, but the sutures of the skull, when you breathe in, they actually expand.
This is what they've found with technology, that this happens in recent research.
And I've researched this, and not all medics do describe the sutures as immovable joints.
In fact, they actually say it would be unhealthy to have completely immovable joints, which makes sense to me.
So they move on the in-breath.
And at the same time, the sacrum, the triangular bit at the bottom of the spine, slightly tilts back.
And this is a wonderful thing.
And on the out-breath, you have...
a more internal sort of activity going with the vagus nerve.
So the tone of the vagus nerve increases.
So the out-breath triggers the chill-out system, the parasympathetic.
So at the end of the day, when you flop down in a chair, you're absolutely washed out.
That's what you're doing.
You may know this anyway, but I'm just saying that the breath,
works with the body all the time in ways we're not really aware.
We just think of this exchange of oxygen, carbon dioxide, but there's all kinds of things going on.
It's amazing.
I mean, the eyes, the cornea of the eye has no circulation.
It only has the air.
The epidermis of the skin, as I'm sure you know, there's no circulation there.
It has the air around it.
You see all these molecules of air, the sea of cheer.
I like to think of it as, but I mean, that's my language.
That's the language I like.
Okay.
But it's all right to think in purely physical terms, of course it is with all of this actually.
So,
It's tremendously important.
Breathing is a living document of our reaction to the outside world.
I do an exercise with fingers like this.
I get distracted because there's a visual display.
Like this, you see.
You hold your hand up like this if you can be patient with me and try it.
And you go one, two, three.
I have to look away because I get distracted by the delay.
Right, so we've got a metric cycle of four there.
We're going back to school.
We're learning something, okay.
now in this hand you do the same thing but you miss off the little finger you go one two three so this is your first exercise we have to put them together at the same time and keep them going okay are you ready after two i want you to get it wrong actually and i maybe i will get it wrong too and that's okay and you'll see why now watch yourself while you're doing it as well i'm afraid you've got to do that too
Watch your breath.
Okay.
One, two.
So after 12 synchronized movements, we realized that the body, the body understands arithmetic, but does your breath, did you notice you were holding your breath?
did i i mean i can't see but when i did it i did it with a class this was including bunty oh i loved it because everybody including it was terrific it was like a chorus line of breath holders it was wonderful why it's counterproductive if you have a problem isolate the the smallest part of that problem that you can and breathe out
why if it's to do with the body and coordination and doing a sequence of movements the reason is that if you're stiff if you lock your knees for instance and try to jump in there you won't get anywhere at all you see you need to be supple and the out breath is the way to do it you see so with sculpting sculpting we've already got a head start with all the things that the breath does anyway so we expand with the stomach then we expand with the stomach
But as you expand, right, the stomach's sort of expanding out just slightly, very slightly, even if you only think it without doing anything, tilt as though you've got a tail, still got a tail.
You've devolved, okay, with a tail like that.
And then you will feel in the lumbar region a lovely sense of, it's a very wonderful sensual feeling, actually, of the curve of the spine.
And as the rib cage expands out, you'll feel it.
But it isn't a stretching of the spine like that, you see.
It would stretch how it needs to, how it wants to.
And then the last bit, like a sniff.
Yeah, not like that, like a sniff.
Okay, so the breath is breathing you.
we don't breathe the breath breathe us this is the idea okay so let's try a cycle and when we get to the top in down you let go you see down kotanga style and then if it's comfortable not if you've got any hernias or anything but if it's comfortable
an abdominal, lower abdominal contraction.
Okay.
Gentle.
Not all teachers teach that, but quite a lot of yoga teachers do teach that.
And I am,
talking about it now because it it's crucial to the the way up this breath ends you see okay so just let's try getting that far okay after two so go one two expand out lift in let go drop coat hanger style and contract all right
now the words are good you can use your own words if you like but say you have expand out lift in drop contract let's try it one more time okay i have to do one two expand out lift in drop contract now
If you can, I wonder if you could stand up.
I haven't got enough room here to organise the perspective that would be required for me to do this with you.
I usually, I never teach like this.
I'm one of these guys that walks around all the time.
I don't know whether that irritates people or not, but it's just, I suppose, a way of directing nervous energy.
I don't know.
So I'm having to sit here.
I've been super glued to a spot against my will.
So could you stand up?
If you can stand up, if not, don't worry.
You can do this lying down, but really standing up for this last bit, even if it's just for one breath to get the thing that I'm getting at, you see is when you contract the lower abdominals or don't contract them.
But at that point also do a buttocks clench.
Okay.
it's a bit like a mullabander only it isn't because with a mullabander you'll be raising your chest but anyway do a buttocks clench okay so if you're standing you stand shoulder width apart toes pointing forward and don't fuss and worry about oh why should my toes be turning out or turning you know don't worry about that
What is important?
You look, you watch animals, how they get their posture right.
They, they go around in a circle until they've got exactly the right spot.
I'm not suggesting you do that.
But what I am suggesting is that you rock it.
If you rock from one foot to another, do you get that feeling of rocking from one foot to another?
Okay.
You will, you will find your comfort, your sort of comfort zone within that, that little area.
you get a sense of being anchored yeah now we're going to do that breath again and at the end clench your buttocks okay so after two one two expand lift sorry my fault let's start again okay so after two one two expand out lift in
drop, clench.
Now hold it.
You can carry on breathing if you like, but hold that clench.
Now what you'll notice is that all the muscles right down to the floor flex just slightly.
And don't you feel rooted?
I'm confident you do.
I'm confident you all feel rooted.
If you have a problem, I'm sorry, obviously you can't help that.
Then you can sit down and think this.
so it's that sense of rootedness and already you've got a wonderful social tool there because if you're in a group you say you're in a group you know that situation where you're in a group and you kind of don't feel very confident you don't you don't feel like a very strong member of the group a bit of an outsider maybe always stand on two feet
that i mean this is just simple body language that most people know anyway but i'm going to say it don't put your weight on one leg because what you're doing the message that goes out is is that you have a weakness now if you stand on two legs on two feet um you will look confident if you stand on two feet like this you will look super confident you see
You feel, you feel that no one can knock you over.
They can, of course, but the point is you're giving out the right message.
So it's good.
It's good to feel confident.
So if you've never done this before, then it would really please me if you find that a good thing to do, that you find it a useful thing and you're enjoying doing it.
Right?
So relax now.
Now we're going to change.
the focus of our attention a bit now.
We're going to think, stay standing, and we're going to think about space between.
I am going to read this because I don't quite know it from memory confidently.
Okay, relax into that posture.
You don't need to keep your buttocks clenched, by the way.
standing alone in stillness one can observe every mystery present at every moment and ceaselessly continuing this is the gateway to indescribable marvels lao tzu and it's used uh
sometimes in describing a series of exercises in qigong called jiang zhong and you you probably all know them because you know it's the holding the imaginary balls and that kind of thing it's it they're tremendous exercise i've done a lot in the past and i've started revising them again actually recently
But you know, the one I love is the first.
And that's what you do now.
You're just standing.
I love it.
And you stand on a railway station and, you know, you miss your train.
Great.
That gives me a chance to practice the first one, which is called Wuchi.
Now, we're not exactly going to practice Wuchi, but what I want you to do is it's just inspired by Wuchi because Wuchi would not, I don't think...
instructors of zhang zhong would ask you to do this but um i want you to do it because it's to do with polarities and it's to do with the space between now okay just calmness
Now, if you place your eyes just a few feet ahead on the floor, or just half close your eyes, you're making, by doing that, a physiological change.
You're moving towards.
By doing that, you're telling the brain,
that you're thinking of sleeping basically towards an alpha state and then a theta state.
So basically it's another way of relaxing and being receptive.
Right.
Okay.
So lift your eyes and I want you to look at the wall in front of you.
Put your attention on the wall in front of you.
nothing strenuous just just look at it now put your attention on your own body in fact you you can just i think you can do this with your eyes closed probably just think of the wall in front of you now your own body one more time
The wall.
Your body.
Now the wall behind you.
And your body.
The wall behind.
Now your body.
Now the wall to the left.
and your body to the left and your body to the right and your body to the right and your body the ceiling
If you're outside, just as high as you can think.
And your body.
Seeming.
Okay.
Now the earth, deep in the earth.
And your body.
deep in the earth and your body.
And now the whole room in your body, the space in the room, sense the Qi, the sea of Qi.
Well, we all know it's air molecules colliding.
But some of us know that it's chi, the dance of chi.
It's a dance.
And I want you to imagine that you picked up a seashell.
Imagine putting it to your ear.
That is the amplification.
of course as you know of the of the air molecules colliding that is the amplification of the song of chi okay and now take a breath a good breath and sigh
now with the sigh if you open your mouth it's approaching the reiki breath with the reiki breath they don't talk about any of this stuff in reiki by the way it's it's uh i haven't heard of it spoken of anyway you know the pranayama the classical yogic breath but what they do do is um specify breathing through the nose
on the inhale and out through the mouth on the exhalation, but the tongue resting on the roof of the mouth on the inhale and dropping down just behind the bottom teeth on the exhalation.
Okay.
So you can try that.
Just try that for a bit.
Okay.
Just on your own.
All right.
it's rather nice actually still trying to let the try to let the the the air scope to the body
Maybe I'm throwing a lot at you.
I don't know.
I mean, I know you will know a lot that I've spoken about, so it helps.
And, and I suspect you've all done spiritual work before, and that counts for a lot in this because you, you, you don't need sort of visual aid, so to speak.
Now, if you want to, you can sit down just in front of your computer and, um,
I'm still here as you can see.
I hope you could hear me okay.
My voice was sufficiently clear for you whilst we were doing all that.
And what I want you to do now is just hold your hands like this, okay?
You hold your hands like this.
in fact it might be a good idea before we start this to just give them a bit of rub get get a bit of heat going a bit of heat this is all very physical you see it's it's magic without magic that's what it is it's all it's all in the physics the friction creates the heat okay now open your hands now you may know this one as well you imagine you've got a ball
in your hand.
Okay.
You've got a ball in your hand and play with it.
Roll it around.
Okay.
Now let it get bigger.
It's getting bigger.
It's a bigger ball now.
It's moving towards, it's moving towards football status.
Yeah.
It's a great feeling.
And now it's moving towards beach ball status.
Yeah.
There it goes.
Okay.
Now just blow it away.
Keep your hands here.
Now I want you to think of these polarities.
left palm right palm left palm right palm carry on doing that don't do anything strenuously
you can make it move a bit you know gradually faster and you can feel energy moving moving between the two hands and it's very palpable if you don't it doesn't matter we're not into sensation we're into we're actually into investigation yeah you might find something different
okay now raise the hands like this just above the head and carry on doing that so left hand right hand or whichever way you want to think all right now this is called the reiki shower okay now i want you to take a good breath in
turn their hands so they're facing like that and bring them down the body and imagine energy like rain imagine it you know sort of dripping off every part of you every every uh no can cranny your elbows your shoulders the tip of your nose right down and then if you sort of shake your hands yeah and then come up again turn your hands
And exhale as you go down.
I forgot to say that.
And imagine going down.
And then up again.
And down.
Then up.
And always finish an exercise with gassho, okay?
It kind of honours the skill.
I knew a woman, she's a very high-flying pianist and kind of academic in music, and her daughter, who's ridiculously talented, you know the kind.
And when her daughter played the piano, she used to get her to sing a song to the piano to thank the piano afterwards.
And it's wonderful.
I think it's a great idea, actually.
It's showing...
respect and it's showing here's a key here's a buzzword it's being used more and more in modern spiritual teaching it's showing gratitude which by some teachers is described as the emotional signature of receivership and there's one researcher a guy called i think he's called greg bray
braden you put you probably know what i'm talking about i'm quite remembered his name there's research back to the apocryphal writing saint thomas and apparently they practiced this this kind of thanking before receiving you see it's it's very powerful and it's to do with it is to do with frequencies it's to do with energy of course but it's good it's good anyway it's a good feeling it's it it has
It has rewards.
So
there there there we have um the reiki shower now the use of this is terrific because you know when you've got a long day i'm fortunate i can do more or less what i like now i i'm sort of retired or not retired i i write a bit of music you know for the media and that's that kind of thing occasionally but um basically i i don't have to turn for work in the morning because i'm a you know i'm a
a dinosaur a retired dinosaur you that would be the day i just i don't want to retire at all um but you know i i used to remember having several hours still today and i was absolutely worn out and i used to do that i'd do i just when no one was looking at just this is the other version of it where you don't bother with starting there but you scoop energy up you see
up to the crown and then down and even if you imagine yourself doing that if you're if you're low in energy it works it does work i mean you know i don't like to think of you having to do it i didn't like being like that i still do get like that sometimes i get tired of course i do but i've considerably more energy
then well 20 years ago i had less energy than now why because i practice pranayama and these energy exercises now i'm i'm looking at the time so i'm that's one exercise i'm just going to show you one other other one quickly and this is called joshin kukioho which is inner cleansing and this is a terrific exercise and
Well, I do some of these exercises walking around.
You feel good.
And there's two versions of this exercise.
I'm going to give you the version that's in the pack.
I'll be sending you a pack tonight.
And I didn't want you to get it too early because I wanted you to digest what Bunty had sent you.
But I'm going to send you this tonight.
And there are two versions.
I'll do the version that is in there.
And then I'll talk about the other version.
you you breathe in draw energy in from the crown imagine doing that or if you find that difficult you see it's really to do with polarities it's focusing on one point and then another point and it can be more than one point and then you know the the energy will find its way
so basically you draw energy through the crown down to the horror or the dantian if you type tai chi using tai chi terminology
just about an inch and a half below the navel but don't think don't think in a precise way like that think of your gut you draw it down to your belly okay you draw it down to your belly okay so draw the energy down or just think of your belly when you when you in inhale and before you exhale just imagine it sort of spreading a little and then as you exhale
out through every part of the the skin system okay every part of the the surface of your body so that it's making a kind of oval balloon and you're you're inside that balloon okay
now this is this is used as a meditation actually i don't i don't use it as a meditation i i i will use either you know what i do with what bunty does i don't do a lot of meditation but in a way all of all of these things are and i think that if you're into vipassana which is a wonderful
it's the king really of of uh exercises really um this will help you help you with your posture and who knows maybe with your concern i don't know okay but uh just try it and so this is a this is a continuous thing so you can do it for a period of time rather than so many times so we imagine drawing energy in and then the balloon begins to
creep out of you.
It's great, isn't it?
Quite extraordinary because I can feel your energy.
You're a very good class.
I can feel it's strong.
It's strong.
It's good.
I walk down the street, you know, sometimes doing this and you feel protected, but I sometimes combine it with metta.
It's a wonderful technique, metta.
And, you know, when we do these things,
we have to think that it is for our highest and greatest good and for the highest and greatest good of those whose lives we touch you can't separate it there is no not anymore i mean you know we've come to a precipice now anyway and i think big things are happening spiritually i mean horrible things are happening of course
yeah but spiritually there's a lot there's a lot happening and i don't think it's the kind of thing that is anticipated by the great powers those builders of empires i don't i don't think they understand that but there is a lot happening and it's wonderful to be part of it
now with self-treatment um because of the time as it is what i'm going to do now is just to show you the the kind of positions of the hands okay um before you start you do you do the precepts uh the gokai which is is five precepts uh to be thankful that that's your gratitude and to be free from anger to be free from fear
be honest which doesn't mean telling the truth it simply means treating people fairly you know not trying to cheat them and to be kind compassionate so i've kind of reduced that down to three statements which is just for today i'll be thankful just for today i'll be free from anger and fear just for today i'll be honest and kind and that's a powerful tool as well
it's real it's it's in our physiology the words are inside us they're part of us and you say that two or three times it prepares you and then you sit quietly find the calm center of yourself and raise your hands and go show
and ask for the Reiki to flow.
Who do we ask?
Who are we asking?
The first thing I thought when I was shown this, we have to give everything a persona, don't we?
We can't accept that intelligence doesn't need a persona all the time.
A persona is like a suit of clothes, that's all.
So what I'm saying is that Reiki is the intelligence of compassion.
It's the intelligence of compassion.
That is the energy.
And it's not an unthinking.
How could it be?
It wouldn't make sense.
It wouldn't make sense at all.
So you asked for it to flow.
And this is the trusting, isn't it?
and how can you feel safe this is why we had a blessing from bunty to make us feel to create a safe place for us to practice but we can create it ourselves and you create it with this reiki's heart driven and when we can breathe from the heart breathe from the heart you know you think of something in your past that makes you happy and breathe it i think uh bunty's hinted at this before
his teachings in the evenings breathe from the heart imagine the breath entering there and going out of there and you think of a good thing that you've experienced yeah like an old man who was absolutely crippled with his spine had more or less gone leaning over so near to the floor old guy
And somebody said, how are you?
How are you feeling today?
And he said, and this was his present to that guy and his present to me and his present to you.
He said, the tears of my laughter flow like a stream into a dry desert.
That's a gift.
That's a gem.
That's a gem he's given us all.
And other people will quote that.
so he's left a legacy just in his response to how are you today you know so breathing from the heart is important in reiki and when we do the positions um i'll just go through the positions because you warm your hands we're not actually doing self-treatment at the moment but we can go through the different positions we start here okay over the eyes
yeah so that covers the frontal lobes where all those crazy loops go on incessantly in a tangled sort of horrific unceasing you know movement when you can't get to sleep it covers those soothes them when if you've got a headache i'll tell you that's the one thing
Reiki, for me anyway, takes it away.
Strangely, it didn't at first.
It did other things, really great things, you know.
But, yeah, don't give up.
If it doesn't work at first, don't give up.
And the eyes, the eyes.
which is supposed to bring in about, I think, about 90% of sensory data.
So they're very important with sighted people, of course, but there are other things that happen.
So that's the first.
And then the temporal, the auditory areas, yeah, to do with the ears, you can put your hands over the ears.
and keep your fingers together make sure your hands are warm and as you come i will instruct you in this when we do it if you imagine your hands rising from the surface of the skin and you relax if you relax and imagine that what will happen is that the hands i'm doing it now i'm not i'm not making any conscious movement i'm just thinking
i'm just thinking of hands right and then you can feel you can feel the heat and something else and then the next position is you could put it either over here so over here you've got of course you're in the area of of movement the motor cortex and fine movement with the fingers very fine movement
um i usually use go for the back rather than that but you can there's no reason why we shouldn't do both so you put your hands like that you know and then at the back as if you you're resting on them but not over each other although we do that at one point so at the back like that so at the back we've again we've got we've got movement
um of a different kind the kind of movement where we have to adjust it's a bigger kind of movements like when you kick a ball or you you're navigating your way across the street and you know adjusting where you are to avoid things and okay which would be the cerebellum i suppose but also of course back there you've got the tiger tiger burning bright aren't you you've got the you've got the raw emotion
know in body language they're probably odd to it now but the guy trying to work a scam you know typical in body language typical they say well i don't know the trouble is the deal runs out and oh my god yeah it runs out tonight but i may be able to i may be able to i just might be the the the hand goes right back there
because back there does not understand lies.
It doesn't understand lies.
It doesn't have morality.
It's not to do with morality.
It just does not understand this peculiar human trait of lying to each other and getting into all kinds of problems.
It doesn't understand it.
So it hurts.
It hurts because it's presented.
It's being presented with nonsense.
So the hand goes.
So that's one position.
And then down around the throat here.
So stimulating the lymph nodes around there.
And this, of course, is the chakra.
I say chakra.
Some people say chakra.
I don't know what you say, but one of those tomato things.
It's the it that is the one to do with expression isn't it in communication around here So on the face then we've got one Two Three and then four okay, and then we have We go then to the body and if you have the fingers touching we go to the heart the heart
and what they found uh found out where i think it was way back in it was a guy research researching called amor strangely enough he had the french word for for love yes and he's called this researcher and he discovered that they were in the hearts
You have 40,000 neurons, I think, which isn't great as neurons go, is it?
But it's what it does.
The heart sends far more messages to the brain than the brain does the heart.
This is what he discovered.
It dictates to the brain.
We didn't think that, did we?
We didn't think that.
Yeah.
yes that the heart dictates to the brain and there's actually a for broke people with broken hearts it's it it is a natural an actual medical condition you know i think i don't know where i can remember it's something like takotsubu cardiomyopathy takotsubu is a it's an octopus an octopus park
You know, I'm laughing, but it's not funny because we've all been, we've all been, most of us have been dumped at some time and your world ends, the sun goes out.
Nothing is beautiful in your world anymore.
You've got takotsubo cardiomyopathy.
I don't know whether it's when it's very, very extreme or something that people get.
That's what happens.
The actual shape of the heart is affected.
love your heart give it lots of love give it lots of love i mean you know often no one else will anyway so you might as well to you might as well have an affair with yourself be your own lover your own partner
and then it doesn't matter it doesn't matter as much what happens you know in the outside world so that's there so the the heart and then here at the lower lower part you're over the thymus now the thymus of course no longer exists because it it it um
it goes doesn't it when we reach out but it's left a lifelong legacy of immune functions you see so that's very important and there's a guy um in daoist medicine see if i can remember his name master manta cheer i think manta cheer it is wonderful to watch because he he does this thing he presses on the thymus
see there and he laughs he laughs and laughs i've got neighbors so i can't i can't so you you laugh and laugh and laugh and laugh and this is what you and he does the same down with the gut as well down down with the gut in the in the in the right in in in the belly you see and
you sort of massage first.
He's a great guy to watch.
I can recommend.
I don't know enough about Taoist health systems or medicine to know.
He seems to be high ranking, but perhaps you can tell me.
I'm sure some of you will know more of this than I do.
Okay, so we've got the heart, then the lower.
And then the stomach, right?
The stomach, just the, just, you know, below the weather navel is basically, and then the hands just slot them into the inguinal fold.
Okay.
So that's the position.
So we go one, two, and then three, four like that.
And then we go the heart, the thymus.
Yeah.
then down in in the tummy and then the inguinal fold and uh tomorrow night we'll do a a longer a god an actual self-treatment thing all right now it's about time i released you and um you've been i can feel that you've been you've been a very good um engaging class that that's been with me
Maybe it's in my imagination.
Well, leave me with that delusion, please.
So breathe well.
Many, many blessings.
Many blessings.
Metta.
Thank you.